what is this the honor system
the honor system as to whether somebody
has been vaccinated
do you want them breathing in your face
on the strength of their honor
nancy if you're breathing near me i'll
wear a mask a hat and a welder's mask
[Applause]
yes all right one thing i've learned
watching the media
it's like drinking tequila you do it on
an empty stomach
i watched two minutes of don lemon after
dinner last night and my wife is still
trying to get the smell of vomit out of
two throw pillows
but also it's amazing how fast they bury
their own mistakes
which maybe they learn from watching
goodfellas they'll report something
that's false
but before anyone has a chance to expose
the lie they've already moved on
and like that hitchhiker i picked up
last august
the story's gone without a trace
so thank god there are people out there
who go back and show us the most
egregious media mistakes during this
particular pandemic
these hacks won't get away with it just
because they were wearing masks
i gotta credit human events christina
pusha charles cook from
national review and the great ann
coulter for exposing this following
media malpractice
so do you remember the story of rebecca
jones
like bernie sanders hair it was
everywhere
a heroic whistleblower accusing governor
ron desantis of demand
of demanding that she falsify data cable
news embraced her like andrew cuomo
groping a terrified female staffer
rebecca jones thank you for your
invaluable work this is very very
important work that you're doing we
greatly appreciate it i know this has
been
uh very hard for you to be in the
spotlight and there are a lot of big
accusations coming your way
so thank you for taking this opportunity
to help us
understand what this is about and what
it means for the people of florida
rebecca jones uh the light is shining on
you
uh don't be scared because the whole
country now uh is watching
you and your family and what they do to
you
but as quickly as you can say michael
avenatti the narrative fell apart
crumbling faster than julie swetnick
under oath
and when it fell apart the press ignored
it like a burning police station in
minneapolis
to remind you after the florida
department of health fire jones last may
she claimed it was for not helping to
falsify or
to boost desantis stats falsely
overnight she became a star forbes
awarded her
technology person of the year proof that
forbes has sunk lower than george
stephanopoulos and bare feet
he is shorter than me she raised
hundreds of thousands of dollars
her twitter followers exploded it was
all about as real as cat's glasses
but that didn't matter
[Laughter]
the media loved her because she fit a
role they needed
to bash an evil pro-trump republican who
was beating the pandemic despite
rejecting full lockdowns in a state
teeming with rabid spring breakers and
people in their late hundreds
those bath salt huffing alligator riding
hillbillies just couldn't be right
now as this is happening the media of
course is embracing andrew cuomo
who shoved coveted patients into rest
homes that killed thousands
might as well have been gas chambers
even as per capita
new york has nearly doubled florida's
coveted 19 fatalities
the only thing higher than new york's
coveted death rate are its taxes
but what about this perfect hero turns
out the lady npr called a top scientist
was about as much of a scientist as bill
nye
in fact she had held three non-scientist
jobs all of them
had her fired and criminally charged
she'd been busted for trespassing
resisting arrest attempting to steal
computer equipment
and in 2018 she was accused of sexual
cyber harassment
facing stalking charges stemming from an
extramarital affair
with her former student her resume is
more of a rap sheet
although it sounds like someone hunter
biden might be into
so she was no doctor she never even
played one on tv
you get better health advice from the
muscle head working at the vitamin shop
according to human events according to
human events
quote case files alleged jones stalked
and robbed her former student
sent explicit photos to his family and
employer and trespassed on his property
sounds exactly like what happened to me
when i switched long distance carriers
so maybe that might have tipped the
media off
no such luck even though all of this
seems like an easy
fact check but the media didn't bother
because they needed a hero
and when the media seeks a hero they'll
overlook the very worst
like this lewd lollipop
[Laughter]
remember how cnn embraced michael
avenatti yet his story had more flaws
than the diamond cat wears on her ring
just let that one simmer but that didn't
stop bry
looking ahead to 2020 one reason why i'm
taking you seriously as a contender
is because of your presence on cable
news
now other than where to go to get the
best blueberry pancakes
does he ever get anything right
remember how they embraced jesse smilet
the guy that did his best acting when
being interviewed by the cops
no remember hoaxers when you hire two
nigerian brothers to fake a hate crime
don't pay by check and i've lost count
of all the questionable sources the
media used in the russian collusion hoax
they flooded the zone with bitter clowns
and spotlight chasers
remember this guy what happened to him i
think he's now jeff zucker's footstool
fact is if the media can nail you
they'll use any tool within reach
including tools with a few screws loose
then they stop covering it when they're
wrong and pretend the whole thing never
happened
they shout the lie to ruin an enemy's
reputation that don't have the integrity
to admit they're wrong
but at least some people are doing the
work that i'm too lazy to do
i wonder what our angry white male has
to say
ah the whistleblower huh yeah i didn't
pay much attention to that story when it
happened
kind of shows you what i think of the
mainstream media that's probably out
hiking like today
which begs the question if a fake
whistleblower blows a whistle
and you're not around to hear it did it
even make a sound
there's definitely something wrong with
that man
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guests
if jokes were joints he'd have them
rolling in the aisles
host of the quiz show on fox nation tom
chalu
[Applause]
he behaved better as a child than cuomo
does as an adult
new york gubernatorial candidate andrew
giuliani
this is the only cash not being ruined
by inflation
former defense department chief of staff
cass patel
[Applause]
and she's the kind of girl you bring
home to mom if you want your mom to take
you out of her will
fox's contributor captain
so andrew welcome to the show it's great
to be on the show with you tonight greg
yeah you know you i remember you being
in the audience once and now you're on
the set
yes i know generally considering what i
did they don't like to let me get on
this
matter as you alluded to before yes so
what do you make
of of kind of these media narratives
you've been in the white house you've
seen how they shape these things and you
know they're not true what's your sense
well you said it absolutely right i mean
they just continue to actually push a
story
whether the narratives are right or not
and the facts don't even matter
true it's true you know tom um you are a
master at manipulating the media because
everybody thinks you're not
a serial killing
um i have to ask you what was that
outfit you were wearing in the last
angry white male
that's just what i like to hike in you
know you go hiking in the woods
[Laughter]
i could tell if you're doing a
commercial for bph
or you're doing a commercial for uh some
other sexual disorder i don't i don't
know what that is i don't know what it
means greg
all right well what do you what's your
take on this incredibly important topic
it is interesting because almost
everything
we have to talk about on this show now
greg is a fake
story yes you know most stories now you
can count on them being fake most of the
stories that break through into the
mainstream media
this type of story though is a special
one because
it's not just a kind of a fake news
story or something that's uh
twisting the narrative what it is is
they needed a story
to counter an actual story which was
that florida's numbers were doing very
well
despite the fact that they weren't doing
lockdowns that story
really bothers people so then they
basically put out a beacon they're like
uh we need to refute this story anybody
anybody
and then she comes calling and then
she's ready to go so it's
this kind of story is the one they want
the most because it they need it to
counter
the story they don't want to tell cash
and i had a boss who used to have a
phrase for that i can't remember what it
was
it rhymes with shake booze oh yes oh yes
yes yeah but you know i remember when
this story came out and this is why i
i like i always say that i'm lazy like i
didn't know
how to ch like how do you verify this
story that all this stuff is like maybe
did santa's really do this
did he really like try to doctor the
numbers of course he's not do you think
he actually needs to do that or has to
or would do that he's no andrew cuomo
[Laughter]
by the way cash so while this is going
on they're like
you got you got andrew cuomo with the
giant q-tip you got his brother
basically you know talking about how
he's single and ready to mingle
you have his nipple rings flailing in
the wind
like little baby fists i don't know what
i'm talking about cash
yeah you know he threw me on the nipple
ring thing uh yeah but
no it's good to be back home in new york
yes yes i'll take it i love
you just follow the nipple rings yes
i've tried that it hasn't worked out in
the past
it seems to for so what is it you um
obviously you
you work in the white house too and you
uh you see these narratives
which ones were the in your mind the
worst
well it's just a continuation of the
same theme donald trump gets elected and
the world blows up and journalistic
integrity gets a flame torch
yeah so pick your topic i ran
counter-terrorism for president trump at
the white house right
yeah we kill the world's worst terrorist
in l baghdad in costume suleimani
and cnn memorializes the guy yes you
know it doesn't matter
human being right we bring we bring
hostages home right
you've been gone for years yes and they
go and say how dare you engage the
syrian government
and so but if obama did it or biden does
it it's the gold standard but they also
have the media available to them to
swallow the headline
the fake headline that they created
because they know no one's going to call
them out
except you and a few others but the rest
of the populist doesn't care they just
don't give a damn because they don't
want to buy into a narrative
of truth that we actually did the right
thing under president trump when andrew
and i were in the white house
it's just too much for them to take i
think you're right i think i
probably am the real hero well i was
trying to give you the you know the gold
star but i was saving that for later
yeah but i i think you i think you hit
the nail on the head
the russian collusion stuff was insane
because like you know
here's the point the fake the fake news
and these narratives exploded so much
because so many interesting things were
being done
and they didn't know how to deal with it
so they just kept making up more
more stories as there were as as there
was like actually good things being done
can i just tell you one thing on the
russian collusion hooks so yeah i ran
the russiagate investigation for house
intel for devon
yeah and as a staffer you're supposed to
be free from the media yeah adam schiff
and his insane clown posse came
out after i after i basically started
unearthing this thing
do you know what they got the media to
call me a staffer at the hill yeah a
genocidal
dictator you can't make it up it's in
print yeah
makes perfect sense that's right but you
know what after your first impression
after you comparing adam's shift to the
legendary insane clown posse
you are a genocidal thing you have a
gigolo right here
i didn't actually went to what did you
get together get the juggalos for
barstool but yes yes yes
and you came back with only four
infections yeah yeah
all bacterial thankfully oh thank god
one that keeps repeating itself
cat okay uh so it seems like the media
has the worst
uh judgment when it comes to selecting
their heroes
is this by accident or is it deliberate
i i think that it has to be something
almost subconscious because it is so
crazy if you break it down
um going back to what tom was saying i
do remember
about a month ago in florida a couple
months ago florida's numbers were
looking great
and uh you know nobody that was liberal
could
actually acknowledge that any of the
liberal liberal governors
they i'm like i please tell me these
people are not continuing to champion
economy crushing policies because they'd
rather do that than admit that a
republican governor is anything short of
a cold-blooded mass murderer
and then i see this story and it's it's
somehow worse right because they had the
choice
either they could believe something that
a republican governor was saying which
would be good news
for them personally and the entire
country
or they could go with a very bad
conspiracy theory
which would be bad for the entire
country being pushed
by a career criminal and they're like
well you know
i'm going to go with rebecca like at
least she's not a republican
it's it's you can't be thinking thoughts
at all and have this be your reaction
she might be a lovable career criminal
though
right
who knows there's still time hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else